travis barker is hospitalized for a
medical emergency and his wife kourtney
kardashian is sticking by her husband's
side through the scary ordeal on tuesday
the blink 182 drummer was reportedly
rushed to la cedar sinai hospital by
ambulance after being seen by docs at
another nearby hospital
outside cedars cameras captured
43-year-old courtney standing beside
travis in all black while paramedics
wheeled him inside on a stretcher and
now a source tells et quote after
speaking with travis and running several
tests dr said travis is suffering from
pancreatitis
before that diagnosis he posted a
cryptic message tweeting god save me
which is also a song he worked on with
machine gun kelly
god save me
and now it seems like travis and his
family are leaning on their faith
through this health scare travis's
daughter alabama asked her followers on
instagram to please send your prayers
and she made the same request in a now
deleted tick tock posting this pick
holding her dad's hand while in a
hospital bed
up until this health scare it's been
newlywed bliss for courtney and travis
[Music]
back in may the couple tied the knot in
italy in an intimate ceremony surrounded
by their loved ones including all the
kardashian barker kids we're just you
know living our best lives and we know
they're interested in expanding the
family their ivf journey played a big
part on season one of the kardashians
hulu show
i'm super grateful that travis is doing
this with me i don't think i can do it
on my own i just feel like it's
something like we have to do together
we're making a baby together court and
travis have been on the same page about
staying on top of their health but their
journey to conceive hasn't been easy our
last egg retrieval was not successful so
our new thing that we're going to be
trying is a panchakarma cleanse which is
ayurvedic it's like 3000 years old
which will
get all of the toxins that are like deep
within our tissue
out of our bodies to have better quality
eggs
we are wishing travis a speedy recovery
you